welcome back everyone this is the 10th
and final screencast in our series on
contextual representation I'd like to
just briefly wrap up in doing that I'd
like to do three things first just take
stock of what we did a little bit
second I'd like to make amends for
really interesting architectures and
innovations that I didn't have time to
mention in the course series and then
finally I'd like to look to the Future
both for the course and also for the
field
let me start by trying to make amends a
little bit for some noteworthy
architectures that I didn't have time
for
Transformer XL is an early and very
Innovative attempt to bring in long
contexts and it does this by essentially
caching earlier parts of a long sequence
and then recreating creating some
recurrent connections across those cache
States into the computation for the
current set of states very Innovative
the ideas for Transformer XL were
carried forward into Excel net and the
core of excelnet is the goal of having
bi-directional context while nonetheless
having an auto regressive language
modeling loss and they do this in this
kind of really interesting way of
sampling different sequence orders so
that you process left to right while
nonetheless sampling enough sequence
orders that you essentially have the
power of bi-directional context
and then diberta is really interesting
from the perspective of our discussion
of positional encoding in that
screencast I expressed a concern that
the positional encoding representations
were exerting in some cases too much
influence on the representations of
words
duberta can be seen as an attempt to
decouple word from position somewhat it
does that by decoupling those core
representations and then having distinct
attention mechanisms to those two parts
my guiding intuition here is that
duberto will allow words to have more of
their wordhood separate from where they
might have appeared in the input string
and that seems very healthy to me
when I talked about Bert I listed out
some known limitations there were four
of them
I gave credit to Roberta for addressing
the first one which was around design
decisions and I gave it credit to
Elektra for addressing items two and
three where two was about the artificial
nature of the Mask token and three was
about the inefficiency of MLM training
in the Bert context
I haven't yet touched on the fourth item
the fourth item is from Yang it all
which is the Excel net paper and Excel
that indeed addresses this concern and
the concern is just that bird assumes
the predicted tokens are independent of
each other given the unmasked tokens
which is oversimplified as high order
long range dependency is prevalent in
natural language and The Guiding idea
behind Excel net is that in having an
auto-regressive language modeling loss
we bring in some of the conditional
probabilities that help us overcome this
artificial statistical nature of the MLM
objective
but remember the interesting aspect of
excel net is that we still have
bi-directional context and this comes
from sampling all of those permutation
orders of the input string really
interesting to think about and also a
lovely insight about the nature of Bert
itself
I didn't get to discuss pre-training
data really at all in this series and I
feel guilty about that because I think
we can now see that pre-training data is
an incredibly important ingredient in
shaping the behaviors of these large
language models so I have listed out
here some core pre-training resources
open book Corpus the pile big science
data Wikipedia and Reddit and I have
listed these here's not really to
encourage you to go off and train your
own large language model but rather to
think about auditing these data sets as
a way of more deeply understanding the
artifacts that we do have and coming to
an understanding of where they're likely
to be successful and where they might be
actually very problematic a lot of that
is going to trace to the nature of the
input data
and then finally let's look ahead to the
Future some current trends to the best
of my estimation this is likely the
situation we're in and what we're going
to see going forward
first it seems like Auto regressive
architectures have taken over you know
that's the rise of GPT but this may be
simply because the field is so focused
on generation right now
and so I would still maintain that if
you simply want to represent examples
for the sake of having a sentence
embedding or understanding how different
representations compare to each other it
seems to me that bi-directional models
like Bert might still have the edge over
models like GPT
sequence to sequence models are still a
dominant choice for tasks that have that
structure it seems like they might have
an edge in terms of an architectural
bias that helps them understand the
tasks themselves although item one here
is important as we get these really
large pure language models we might find
ourselves moving more toward Auto
regressive formulations even of tasks
that have a sequence to sequence
structure we shall see
and then finally and maybe this is the
most interesting point of all
people are still obsessed with scaling
up to ever larger language models but
happily we are seeing a counter movement
towards smaller models I've put smaller
in quotes here because we're still
talking about artifacts that have on the
order of 10 billion parameters but that
is substantially smaller than these
really really massive language models
and there are a lot of incentives that
are going to encourage these smaller
models to become very good we can deploy
them in more places we can train them
more efficiently we can train more of
them and we might have more control of
them in the end for the things that we
want to do so all the incentives are
there this is a moment of intense
Innovation and a lot of change in this
space I have no idea what these small
models are going to be able to do a year
from now but I would exhort all of you
to think about how you might participate
in this exciting moment and help us
reach the point where relatively small
and inefficient models are nonetheless
incredibly performant and useful to us